.
WE REALLIT. >>U.
>> JUST A LOGTI
ANSTAT DINK,EAENOUGH TEST
PP PEOPLE TO
ACTUAL S DOING TH
>> INKTHERE'S TWO REALLY PIECES
PLATFORM THAT R
TESTS, AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
SPENT THE WREH GOVERNMEN GOVERN
TO REALLY UNDERSTA DEP OHAT
CAN RUN THESE TESTS IN THEIR
STATE IN T CIT A
REALLY
THE'RE MRY
CDC HAS 500PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
THE  EUR THAT
THER EVERY TO
REALLYPORT LOCALND THETATE TO RG
CRITER AND DETERMINEXALYHEY  WHS
DONE.>> WE'OI TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT
BIRX.
AN FOR YOURSERVICLY APPREATECIGE
HEARIMATES THAT, YOU ,
YOU COULD NEED HUNDREDS OF
THOUND TOADEQLYCTAC WE'RE LEARNF
HAVE SYMPTOMSND IN THE
PRE-SYMPTOMATIC PHASE THEY COULD
BE ME
DO WE HAVENO INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THE W WE
NEED TO?
>> I THAT'S WHY THE
CRITER T C SEE THE --
THAT THEER GOVERNMENT HAS RECOM
AND TSE STATESEAY TO THEY'RE
CONTAC T WITH
SUPPORTING.
PIECES
GE NEEDMOVE FORWARD THE NEXT FE
EK THE STATES ME THR REA THE CA
AGAIN, I TO WE KNOW L INDICATOR
AND WENOW THAT'S GOING TOIN A D
INTO THIS WE  T THIS
NOT B YOUR  IF
STATE IS TO,
1,000 PEOPLE OR 00DOON
WITHHE PUBLIC HEALTH DENT AND TS
TH THAT  FED
GOVERNMENT WILVEAT
>> WE,THEC. THE ACT THECDC FOR O
REALLYEN
HEPONSIVENESS A LE AND THAT'S
GOING TO  CRITICAL, BOTH FOR
RI A POTENTIAL FORE IN THE FALL
THEBI
D. TO N HAVE WORKING NOTYLYSTUT.
>> DR. BIRX,
OUSLY, YOU UD AND DR.
FAUCI, HAVE SAIDES THE
BEGINNINT W
INADEQUATE.
AS WE GO FO IF YOU LOOK ATTHEDS
SA T HAVE TO HAVE SAFE AND
TESTING, BUT WE'
HEARING FRO STATES THAT THEYE T
THIS. HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GO IN TERMS
EQUIPMENT, FOR
ESS
GOING FORWARD TO  TESBE TESTED,E
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
>> H AT THE TK
FORC LEAVE AERALTASK FORCE THATS
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STAS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT A -- THIS ISN'
SS AS A ENTIFY ALL THEBORATORI,.
IFT FD DONE,
JU LASTHREE
WE'VE MOV FAS
PHYNGEALO SINGLEPOLYESTER SWAOW
IZ MOVEDM VIRALPORTLL THE WAYS.
KDS CSIBLEHEFDA ABOUT WHAT T A
ALTERNATIVES AND REALLY DOIING
FEDERAL GORNOTTE
SAMEAN,ARE WE'T HAVE TH
RESOURCES TO HIRE0 OEOE CONTACT
AND COMPANIES RAPID TESTING SEE
CAN GO TORK.
YEAH, YOU,  T KEYMENT IN
TH AND
KY FIGGUT
COMBINATION OF POINT OF CARETES
THOSE NOW, TOUGHPUTS REALLYUSEV
D HAVECOVEREDN
HIV/AIDS IS YOUY MATCH THE N TO
LLYHROUGHAT,NG ALL OF
ALIGNMENT.
THAT'S PART OF S T RIGHTW, IS TO
Y
THAT EQUIPMENT HEPOINFTS AND HO
WE NEED TO WORK
REALLY THAT ALIGNMENT.W IT SEEMU
LIMITED  AND WE'VEN TO AGNEED W
CAPACITY SO THAT YOU C REALLYRE
BIRX,US
LET'S SAY ANDERSON ISAC WORK AT
NEW YORK IS -OPENING. SCENARIOSC
HEALTH OFFICIALS PEOPLEEED
TO GET WEEK, MAYBE FREQUENTLY TA
THEY WALE . COULD TBE
CASE, THAT YOU ND TESTED RBASIS?
>> WE 14THESTATES DISEASE WE
TESTLION WORKERS ON A
WEEK BASIS, AND IHINK THAT'SEO C
SMART ENOUGH THAT COMBINECE OPP
E COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE VIRUS
DOESN'T COME
IT HAS TO BE IN TH
COMMUN WHYAVE REALLY C OF
SURVEILLAN, EARLY WARNIST THE
INFLUENZA-LIKE TTEST.
ANY ONE P WILLBLEISH WHAT WE. TF
THE STATE THE SURVEILLANCE
AND T ACTIVITIES T W
REALLY UNDERSTAND BECAUSE STATES
HAVES, NG
INFLUENZA-LIKE ILLNESS, RT SYST.
USING TT EARLY ALE STE
WITH SURVEIL TESTING
G,  HAVE COMETE SO THAT
THAT WL KNO E IADDITION,F IT
LL TT
TRACING APS
AROUND TO SURGE BOTH AND TESTIN
IN THAT PARTICULARCOMMUNITY.>>
NEW .ENT INST. E
PATIENECOVEREDE
CORONAVIRUS,ES THEN EDVIRUS., T
VACCINES A
ANTIBODY TESTS?
DR. BIRX?
>> THIS IS- AHSREALLY IMPORTANTT
TALKS ABOUT FINDING
FRAGMENTS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT'S FUL
LENGTHRNA,EO WILL SHED AS
IAL
ELEMENTS OF RNA.
E  AREYSENSITIVE.
THEY S
RNA.
THE JURY I REALL TDETA ITH STUD
FULL-LENGTHTIOUSVIRUS?
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT'S STILL
STUDIES TO DAT ALTHOUGH PEOPLE
DURING THE VIRUS SEEFTPOTENTIAL
>> I GUESS THE W WOULD HAVE BEET
OU CO, YOU KNOW, INLOGY YOU NEV
THATT
I ME, CERTA OUT
A FIELD WHERE DON'T HAVE
EFFECTIVE OFTY,E DEVELOPAN IMMU,
SUME BUT THERE'S
ALWAYS THAT PER C
PERSON W DOESN'TE ANTIBODY OR F
EASON DOESN'T HAVE
EFFECTIVE NEUTROPHILS POINTS
OUT A LEFECT WASN'T
EVER DISCOVERED IN T GENET
RESP TUNE
RE AVIRUS.
OSLIS EXIST,